joining us now is the shadow Minister
for leveling up Alex Norris hi it's good
to see you thanks for joining us on the
program
talk to us about this mayoral candidate
and his behavior the suggestions alleged
Behavior suggestions are that he should
step aside while there is an
investigation by the cabinet office uh
Daniel corski what do you think yeah I
mean it's whenever you wake up to these
stories or you read these stories on
social media it's not good for politics
because people think here we go again
it's really important for the person
who's been brave enough to come forwards
and for the person who's been accused so
that's to be a proper process so I think
that you know we've done as a labor
party we have an independent process
there's one now being done with the
cabinet office but you know it's right
that that process be taken and that it
run its course yeah my question is
should he step aside while that can
well I think you'll have to consider his
position as to whether you really can
fully you know he's going to get
questions about this every day I think
it's very difficult for him to carry on
it's not really for me to say what
conservative candidates can and can't do
would you expect labor candidate to do I
think I'll explain yeah
um let's see what happens thank you for
that doctor strikes um how much does
labor support uh senior doctors who earn
well over a hundred thousand pounds a
year at least to go on strike well it's
not what we want to see you know as I
know we've had these discussions
previously okay we don't want to see you
know crucial public servants on strike
you know we have to take it seriously
when they think it's got to the stage
where they have to withdraw their labor
but we've been through this process now
for 18 months let's get to the end game
of this this is only ever resolved by
dialogue which is soon actually to get
around the table who's able to do like
with Boris Johnson and his honors get
around the table negotiate a solution so
are you supporting Sydney doctors in the
strike or not just well as I say it's
not what we want to see no absolutely so
you're not supportive it's sad that it's
got to the stages for the government to
resolve it if we were in government we
would be round the table getting it
results we're not supporting them just
to be clear as I say it's not what we
want to see okay
um talk to me uh about housing I know
that your boss
um Lisa nandi will be sending out
Labor's housing reform plans later on
today
um
how do they differ from what we're
expecting or what we've know so far from
the conservatives because the speech has
been called Tory light yeah well I mean
obviously I wouldn't accept that
characterization the difference tell me
how it's different they differ
significantly firstly the government in
December brought in a range of of
planning changes that will completely
reduce Supply we would reverse them so
having local targets making local
authorities collaborate with their
neighbors we would reinstitute that
immediately we also would bring in
protections for first-time buyers so
that people who are buying off planners
on big volume actually the first step
should go to local people so we would
bring that in as well we also would have
extra stamp Duty for people buying from
abroad to tilt the balance towards local
uh local people trying to buy their
first home and then on top of that the
key thing in this is about land Supply
and you know at the moment we have this
kind of really broken conversation about
Greenbelt we've made you've heard
kistama make promises you'll hear less
than like similar promises later about
being Bolder around that we think that's
the right thing to do but also releasing
you know in communities like mine with
lots of former industrial land releasing
that land at the moment developers are
just sat on so I'm conscious that's
quite a few things to check at you they
care but very very different to the
government and we'll hear more from Lisa
Andy as you said in a speech little bit
later on in Salford I mentioned Kirsten
with our prime minister's questions
later on today
um kirst armor accusing Richardson of
being out of touch to understand the
cost of living pressures this is a man
who 10 years ago your boss was earning
200 000 pounds a year how in touch is he
well this is a man whose whole life has
been devoted to Public Service he yes
you know the director of public
prosecution should be paid a significant
salary he got that by being a brilliant
prosecutor and being the top one in the
country I think it's a really big
difference there actually between that
and what kids talking about no what he's
saying is he's a billionaire and so he
can't possibly be uh in touch with the
cost of living pressures I'm putting it
to you that 10 years ago Kia's number
was earning more than 200 000 pounds a
year so how in touch is he with people
struggling to pay their bills well I
think if you see through you know the
quicker action whether it was on
originally if we go back a year or so
ago who was first to call for a windfall
types
you know worry about paying the bills
and Frank no but that's an honest
conversation all politicians have to
because I don't either so you know we we
have to have a touch of you well not
nearly as much as a billionaire and
that's the reality Rishi sunak you know
doesn't operate you know his interests
when it comes to the electricity grid is
how to heat his pool when it you know
when he was talking about mortgages last
week of prime minister's questions it's
like talking to someone who really has
no kind of grasp on it at all so you
know the public at the end of the day
will make their judgment on this I think
we've got a leader who understands what
people are struggling with at the moment
has active ideas to tackle them and we
don't think the prime minister's doing
that what's to be done about Thames
water they've been let down by their
bosses haven't they well it's a mess you
know this is what this is an industry
where dividends have been going out the
door at huge rates debts on these
companies has been has been ratcheted up
we know from all the disaster of of
um of sewage being pumped into our
rivers and oceans that they've not been
doing the day job on on infrastructure
and now you know breaking news overnight
from yourselves here at Sky say that
one's got into trouble we need the full
details of that we think the government
should come today to Parliament until
these have these companies like the
water company has been bled dry uh by
the people that have owned them the
dividends that are being paid out are
ridiculous yeah well we we have said
throughout that you know there is
clearly an inequacy between the
dividends that have been going out the
door and the debt that's been Laden on
these companies and the failure over
multiple decades to really put in uh the
right money into infrastructure so you
know people will rightly ask that
questions we need the full facts you
know this is a story of breaking news
rather than one with a hard balance
sheet in front of us today but we need
those facts that's why the government
should come to Parliament today and say
what's going on and what they intend to
do I'm sure you'll be asking about it uh
during prime minister's questions great
to see you thanks so much indeed for
joining us on the program thanks Alex